[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله اهلا بكم في حصاد
الليله معكم محمد كريشان وفي الوقت الذي
احدثكم فيه الان تقع واحداث
وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من ستاد لوسيل في
قطر وترقب لانطلاق الشوط الثاني من مباراه
هولندا والارجنتين في دور الثمانيه في
مونديال قطر 2022 والشوط الاول الذي يتقدم
فيه الارجنتين بهدف دونالدز
الى العاصمه الامريكيه واشنطن
وتحديدا البيت الابيض الذي حذر اليوم من
شراكه دفاعيه كامله بين موسكو وطهران قال
انها تلحق ضررا باوكرانيا والدول المجاوره
لايران وكذلك المجتمع الدولي
العاصمه الروسيه الان موسكو
انه سيكون من الضروري في نهايه المطاف
التوصل الى اتفاق لانهاء النزاع في
اوكرانيا معربا عن شكوكي في الثقه التي
يمكن ان تمنحها موسكو لمحاوره
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
في الرياض ذمه خليجيه تؤكد التكامل بين
دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي قمه عربيه صينيه
غير مسبوقه تسدد على تطوير العلاقات
الاستراتيجيه وتلتزم بالتنسيق في مصالح
الجانبين والرئيس الصيني يتحدث عن مرحله
جديده في الشراكه الصينيه الخليجيه
العربيه
البيت الابيض يحذر من تنسيق العسكري واسع
بين روسيا وايران ويقول انه يرقى لشراكه
دفاعيه ويكشف عن عقوبات على ثلاث كيانات
المركز وروسيا تتهمها بدعم استخدام سيارات
الايرانيه في اوكرانيا
حضرتك
بالسائل الحصول على مئات الصواريخ
البالستيه من طهران
انقسام الاوروبيه بشان فرد شعر الغاز ست
دول من الاتحاد تعلن معرضتها لتوسيع نطاق
السقف المقترح وتدعو الى ما سمته اليه
لتصحيح السوق والبنك المركزي الاوروبي
يحذر من انهيار الاستقرار المالي وتركيا
تبحث مع روسيا ان شاء مركزا لتوريد الغاز
في تركيا
في لقاءنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا معكم سياقه لقاء جمع في
اسطنبول الدبلوماسينا من روسيا والولايات
المتحده في وقت سابق اليوم وسطا قطيع
الدبلوماسيه بين موسكو وواشنطن
هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال
التاليه الذي يقول برايكم ما احتمالاته ان
يؤدي اجتماع اسطنبول لاستئناف المحادثات
بين موسكو واشنطن حول قضايا كبيره نحو 25%
قالوا ان الاحتمالات كبيره في حين قال 36
بالمئه الى الاحتمالات محدوده في الحقيقه
اخيرا رجع تسعه وثلاثون بالمائه انه
الاحتمالات على الاطلاق
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا كالعاده على
منصاتنا الركبيه ويمكنكم دخوله صفحه
التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر حاليا
على شاشه
خلاله لقضايا مستجدات ومتفاعله عربيا
ودوليا
وبعد الحصاد مباشره وتحديدا للساعه 12:05
بتوقيت مكه المكرمه يتابعون معنا الجوله
الرياضيه اليوميه يوميات المونديال التي
ترصد بالخبر والتحليل مباريات كاس العالم
قطر 2022
[موسيقى]
العاصمه السعوديه رياض ثلاثه قمه خليجيه
خليجيه
وصينيه خليجيه وعربيه صينيه وفي ختام
القمه العربيه الصينيه شدد القاده العرب
في البيان الختامي على اهميه تطوير
العلاقات الاستراتيجيه مع الصين لتشمل
جميع المجالات كما التزموا بالتنسيق في
قضايا تمثل مصالح مشتركه
المتبادله قوه دافعه للعلاقات المشتركه
على دعم للجانب العربي في ايجاد حلول
للقضايا الشركه في المنطقه
النشاط الدبلوماسي الاكبر في تاريخ الصين
مع العرب هكذا تصف بجين زياره الرئيس كيجن
بنج للرياضه دفعه واحده يلتقي الرجل 16 من
قاده البلدان العربيه وممثلهم في قمم
ثلاثه قمه صينيه سعوديه وقمه صينيه خليجيه
سبقتها قمه لدول مجلس التعاون الخليجي
وقمه صينيه عربيه
جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه تحت قياده فخامه
الرئيس يجيبهم قصه نجاح تتجلى في مكانه
الصين الرائده الاقتصاديه العالميه وتولي
دون الاهميه القصوى لرفع مستوى الشراكه
الاستراتيجيه مع جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه
للجهود لتعظيم مكاسب هذه الشراك كما تتطلع
دون مجلس التعاون وتبادل الخبرات
مستوى جديد للعلاقات وما بدا كلمه السر في
تصريحات جيم بنك يفتح بها الباب لعلاقه
تتجاوز افق التبادل التجاري المتقدم اصلا
بميزان يتجاوز 330 مليار دولار مع مجمل
الدول العربيه كلمه السر تبحث عن مساحات
شركه تتيح حضور صينيا اكبر في المنطقه
بمعان اكثر وهي تواصل ما تعرف بمبادره
الحزام والطريق
على الجانبين الصيني والعربي ان يتمسك
بالاستقلاليه والمصالح المشتركه ونحن ندعم
جهود الدول العربيه لاستكشاف الطرق
التنمويه التي تتماشى مع ظروفها الوطنيه
وتساعدها في التحكم في مستقبلها وان يكون
مصيرها في ايدها الصين تحرص على تعليق
الثقه الاستراتيجيه المتبادله مع الجانب
العربي وذلك للحفاظ على سياده البلدان
وكرامتها الوطنيه على الجانبين التمسك
بمبدا عدم التدخل في الشؤون الداخليه
وبالحقوق المشروعه ولنميه
رؤيه ثانيه لا يمكن عزلهما عن طرفي الزمان
والمكان الصين منافسه الولايات المتحده
الابرز تزور الخليج في زمن تزداد فيه حده
التجاذبات العالميه في ملفات عده ابرزها
سقوط الطاقه
تختتم زياره الرئيس الصيني للرياض بعد قمه
من ثلاث تحاول فتحه افاق ابعد للعلاقه قمم
وجدت اصدارها عالميا وفتحت باب التساؤلات
عما سيكون بعدها عدنان ولينا الجزيره
الرياض
وفي ختام القمه العربيه الصينيه قال وزير
الخارجيه السعوديه ان القمه العربيه
الصينيه تعد نقطه انطلاق جديده بين الدول
العربيه وجمهوريه الصين الشعبيه مشددا في
مؤتمر الصحفي على اهميه تعزيز العلاقات
الاستراتيجيه بين الصين ودول الخليج
العربي
وجمهوريه الصين الشعبيه لتحقيق التنميه
المشتركه ودفع ودفعه قويه وتعزيز علاقات
الصداقه الراسخه التي تربط دول المنطقه
بجمهوريه الصين الشعبيه
شهاده القمه السعوديه الصينيه عقد جلسه
مباحثات بين القياده الرشيده حفظها وفخامه
الرئيس الصيني ركزت على تعزيز الشراكه
التاريخيه والاستراتيجيه المتميزه بين
البلدين واستثمار امكاناتها السياسيه
والاقتصاديه في خدمه مصالحهما المشتركه
هذا وقد اعلنت الدول العربيه والصين حرسها
على مواصله التشاور السياسي بشان القضايا
المتعلقه بمصالح الجانبين وتعزيز الشراكه
الاستراتيجيه بينهما وقد اكد البيان
الختامي للقمه العربيه الصينيه في الرياض
تعزيز التضامن بين الطرفين في المحافل
الدوليه وجاء في البيان الختامي لقمه
الرياض الالتزام الجانبين باحترام سياده
الدول ووحده اراضيها وعدم التدخل في
الشؤون الداخليه واكد ان تايوان جزء لا
يتجزا من الاراضي الصينيه واعلن رفض
استقلالها كما اكد بيان قمه الرياض ان
القضيه الفلسطينيه مركزيه في الشرق الاوسط
وتتطلب ايجاد حلل عادل ودائم لها على اساس
حل دولتين وشدد البيان على بطلان ممارسته
اسرائيل الاحاديث الرابيه الى تغيير الوضع
القائم في القدس
واكدت القمه على اهميه دور الوصايه
الهاشميه على المقدسات الاسلاميه
والمسيحيه في القدس وحمايته وهويتها
العربيه
وداع البيان الختامين كذلك الى عقد مؤتمر
الدولي السلام
مسمنا الرؤيه ذات النقاط الاربعه التي
ترحها الرئيس الصيني لحل القضيه
الفلسطينيه
وقد عقد امير دوله قطر الشيخ تميم بن حمد
ال ثاني جلسه مباحثات الرسميه مع الرئيس
الصيني جيش بنك على هامش انعقاد القمه
الخليجيه الصينيه والقمه العربيه الصينيه
في الرياض وفي تغريدات على حسابه على
تويتر قال امير دوله قطر ان القمم الثلاث
نجحت في تعزيز العلاقات التاريخيه بين
العرب واصدقائهم الصينيين بما يحققوا
مصلحتهم المشتركه ودعم الامن والسلامه في
المنطقه والعالم وعرب امير قطر عن سعادته
بمباحثته مع الرئيس الصيني قائلا ان
العلاقات القطريه الصينيه يسودها الاحترام
المتبادل والعمل المشترك في كافه مجالات
التنميه
جمال تقى الرئيس الصيني جيش بنت مع ولي
عهد الكويت الشيخ مشعل الاحمد الجابر
الصباح ونقلت وكاله رويترز عن الرئيس
الصيني القول ان بلاده مستعده لمواصله
العمل مع الكويت كشريك الموثوق والمشاركه
بنشاط في بناء المشاريع الكبرى في الكويت
معنا الان من الرياض جهه ساو الخبير
الصيني في شؤون الشرق الاوسط ومعنى كذلك
من الكويت الدكتور عبد الله الشايجي استاذ
العلوم السياسيه في جامعه الكويت ورحب
بضيفنا نبدا من ضيفنا من الرياض سيد
ما هي ابرز الافاق التي فتحتها هذه القمه
في علاقه الصين مع العرب
نعم هذا سؤال وجيه للغايه لان اليوم كانت
هناك ثلاثه قيمه واحده مع الدول الخليج
والاخرين كانت
للعلاقات الثنائيه بين الدول العربيه
والصين وبالتالي فهذا لغايه الاهميه كوقت
للقاء هذه الدول والتبادل الاراء والحديث
عن التعاون المستقبل لانه في العقود
الماضيه شاهدنا ان الصين
تحاولت
علاقات جيده مع كل الدول الخاصه الدول
الخليج من مساء
الطاقه
الاقتصاديه والصيد داود ان تتعمق ذلك في
اسواق الخارج البلاد واعتقد ان الدول
العربيه ايضا داود ان تجد قدراتها في
المستقبل
ان اي من الطرفين لا يود ان يعتمد على فقط
على الاقتصاد ليقوم على النفط طبعا الصين
طرف واحد دكتور عبد الله شاجي بينما
الاطراف العربيه هناك مجلس التعاون خليجي
وهناك بقيه العرب هل تعتقد بان القمه نجحت
في ان يكون لكل هؤلاء الصوت واحد مسموع
وواضح
بالنسبه الى التجاره والاستثمارات وهمم
مشروع الصين الكوني العالمي طريق الحزام
والطريق الواحد الكثير من الدول العربيه
ستستفيد وهو بعد تجاري واستثمار مهم جدا
همم يشمل ثمانيه مليون دولار 138 دوله في
القارات العالم كلها ولكن يعني نضع الامور
في سياقه يعني الصين مهتمه ان يكون لديها
همم نموذج ناجح همم النموذج الشمولي
الاشتراك الشيوعي تثبت بانه ناجح تلعب دور
اساسي في تشكيل النظام متعدد الاقطاب هي
وروسيا امريكا ليست قلقه كثيرا من حضور
الصيني همم تشعر ان هناك لن يكون في تعاون
استراتيجي بين دول الخليج وبين الصين همم
الصين ايضا يعني لاعب همم تريد ان تنتشر
في المنطقه همم هذا المشروع الضخم عبر
الطرق الطريق البري- طريق الحريري القديم
وعمره الحزام الذي يربط الموانئ التي
الصين تسعى اليها عبر تقديم قروض ثم تحصل
على قواعد عسكريه فالصين تتدرج بان تكون
قوه عظمى في اقليمها ثم تتوسع الى بقيه
العالم زياره تشيكن بينج اللي هو يعد اقوى
شخصيه واقوى زعيم صيني منذ منذ موت
في الصين مهمه جدا لان يكون عندنا يعني ما
نسميه مستوى اخر من العلاقه مع دوله مهمه
ثاني اكبر اقتصاد في العالم اكبر دوله
بعدد السكان وهمم مليار و400 مليون ولكن
في حدود لهذه العلاقه لن تكون استراتيجيه
الصين لا تفكر ولا تقدر وليس لديها القدره
لان تملا فراغ ما اسمي على الكفاء
الامريكي همم عن المنطقه
الدكتور عبدالله
من البيان الختامي على الاقل
ساو سواء في الحديث عن الديمقراطيه او
حقوق الانسان او تايوان يبدو وكان الدول
العربيه همم بدت اكثر تفهما لوجهه النظر
الصينيه في هذه المسائل اكثر من
الوجهه النظر الامريكيه التقليديه
لوضع الاقتصادي العالمي والوضع اللي ظهر
بعد بعد كل هذا كل الدول تود اطلع الى
المزيد من التعاون
وحتى في الغار دول الغرب والشعوب ما تزال
تعيش فيها عصيده ويفكرون بارتفاع معدلات
التضخم انا عندما
همم
العربيه السعوديه الناس الحياه تعيشون
حياه افضل اعتقد ان الصين
لديها كثير من الخلافات مع الغرب ولكن
ايضا الصين تتمتع بتقليد جيد من الصداقه
مع معظم الدول العربيه في خلال عقود
الماضيه واعتقد ان المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
جيده جدا
بالنسبه للدول الخليج ايضا تستفيد من هذه
الروابط مع الروابطها مع الصين والصين
الان لا تريد فقط ان تعتير على هذا النمط
فابلت تحاول ان تكون بان اخرى وهذا ليس
بالسهل طبعا نظرا لوجود الوضع الحالي
والسياسه الدوليه علينا ان نتاكد على بان
الشركاء انا في العالم العربي
فائده للطرفين وليس نموذج عمل فقط تنقله
الصين عن الماضي
الذي اثرت اليه همم هل هو سياق دولي مناسب
يجعل الصين ربما تكون مستفيده من هذه
العلاقه العربيه اكثر من استفاده العربي
منها
يعني صحيح لحد ما امريكا طبعا وكافيه ولكن
غير منصبه
عندها اكثر من 30,000 جندي من الكويت الى
مسقط عند
12 13 قاعده بشويه وبحريه وجويه
هذا السبب امريكا موجوده ولكن الاهتمام
والاولويه لمنطقه الخليج تراجعت ولكن حرب
اوكرانيا اعاده المركزيه لمنطقه الخليج
كمصدر الرئيسي لان الطاقه والنفط والغاز
واا دول الخليج وامريكا تفهم ذلك بانها هي
الزبون الاول او الشريك الاول للصين
منتجاتنا في النفط والغاز همم الدوله
الاولى التي تستورد الطاقه من دول
الخليجيه الصين ولهذا السبب الصين لديها
اهتمام كبير بان يكون هناك في استقرار ان
يكون هناك في حضور للصين الشركات
التكنولوجيه وكذلك ما تملكه الصين من
قدرات اليوم تكلم الرئيس الصيني في كلام
عن همم نشر اللغه الصينيه في الجامعات
التعاون توصل الى بالفضاء وكذلك همم يعني
جي 6 جي 5 وجي 6 لامريكا تصنفها مركز يعني
مصدر للتهديد الامن الوطني علينا ان نكون
حريرين تقاربنا مع الصين يجب ان لا يفهم
بانه تقارب استراتيجي من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لاننا لا يمكننا ان نعول على
الصين الصين لا تملك حتى ما نسميه
بالدراسات الاستراتيجيه بلو وتر نيفي ما
عندها اسطول بحري عميق عندها حاملتي
طائرات حديثتين غير مجربتين الصين ليس
لديها القدره ولا الاراده ان تملا
الانتفاء او التراجع الامريكي الذي لن
تنسحب من المنطقه والمنطقه المهمه في كل
ذلك علينا ان نفهم ايضا ان الصين وقعت
اتفاقيه مهمه جدا العام الماضي همم يعني
همم الخصم اللدود لدول المستعان خليجي
وخاصه السعوديه التي العلاقه مقطوعه مع
ايران عنده 2016 اتفاقيه ربع قرن 400 ملي
الدولار وفي همم طياتها شكرا قاعده قواعد
عسكريه صينيه في ايران فكيف يمكن للصين ان
تطمئن الاهن دول الخليج وهذا النقطه لا
احد يذكرها همم تطمن دول الخليج بهذه
الاتفاقيه 400 مليار دولا 25 سنه ما اعتقد
الصين ستوفي بها مقابل شراء النفط والغاز
الايراني كيف ينعكس هذا على تحالفنا والان
الاحتفاليه الكبيره
بالتقارب والعلاقه مع الصين وهذه نقطه جدا
ملفته ان الصين يعني 400 مليار التوقيع
الاتفاقيه كما طلعنا اليوم معنا السعوديه
30 مليار فقط بينما مع ايران 400 مليار
خلال 25 سنه شكرا لك من الكويت الدكتور
عبد الله شكرا لك من الرياض
[موسيقى]
اجرا دبلوماسيون روس وامريكيون مباحثات في
مدينه اسطنبول التركيه وقال نائب وزير
الخارجيه الروسيه
المصادر القلق بالنسبه الى الطرفين اما
الرئيس الروسي فقد قال انه سيكون على جميع
اطراف الازمه في اوكرانيا في نهايه المطاف
القبول بالوضع على الارض بينما قال الرئيس
الاوكراني ان الصيغه التي تتمناه
10 نقاط بينها الامن النووي واستعادته
وحده الاراضي وكذلك امن الطاقه
لم تكن العلاقه بين روسيا والولايات
المتحده على ما يرام عندما انطلقت الحرب
في اوكرانيا فبراير الماضي لكن هذه الحرب
زادت العلاقات سوء حتى بدا في بعض الفترات
وكان البلدين وصل الى قطيعه شبه تامه الان
يجري دبلوماسيون روس وامريكيون اتصالات في
مدينه اسطنبول التركيه قال سيرجيري نائب
وزير الخارجيه الروسي الى الاجتماع
اسطنبول خصص لمناقشه القضايا التي تثير
قلق الطرفين واضاف ان هناك املا في ان
تعود العلاقات بين موسكو واشنطن الى
طبيعتها مع الوقت واكد يا كوب ان روسيا لن
تقترحها ايضا على الولايات المتحده اجراء
مفاوضات بشان الضمانه الامنيه التي تخلت
عنها واشنطن بحجه الاحداث في اوكرانيا حسب
تعبيره يؤكد كلام رياض كوب ان قنوات
الاتصال قد فتحت من جديد ويدمح الرئيس
بوتن الى استعداد للتفاوض على اساس
الوقائعه على الارض
العمليه العسكريه تسير بشكل طبيعي ولا
مشاكل تواجهها اما مسار التسويه بشكل عام
فنعم ربما لن يكون سهلا وسيحتاج وقتا
معينا جميع المشاركين في هذه العمليه
سيتعين عليهم في نهايه المطاف القبول
بالوقائع على الارض
قال رئيس الروسي ايضا ان عمليات تبادل
السجناء اخرين ممكن مع الولايات المتحده
ما يعني ان هذه العمليات يمكن ان تبقي
قنوات الاتصال مفتوحه عمليه تبادل السجينه
الامريكيه بالسجين الروسي حركت المياه
الراكده في العلاقات الامريكيه الروسيه
تم الاتفاق عليها بين مخابرات البلدين
لكنه اوضح انه ليس لها اي تاثير على مجمل
علاقات البلدين التي قال انها تبدو سيئه
يبدو ان الملاذين ارغبان في ابقاء قنوات
الاتصال مفتوحه لكن لا يتوقع ان تعود
العلاقات الى طبيعتها ما دامت مستمره في
اوكرانيا وما دامت الولايات المتحده تدعم
اوكرانيا باسلحه متطوره وتفرد مع باقي
الدول الغربيه عقوبات على موسكو
على مدى اشهر الحرب في اوكرانيا حافظت
الولايات المتحده وروسيا على قنوات اتصال
المفتوحه ورغم انها كانت تنقطع في بعض
الفترات لان ملفات مختلفه تعيد الطرفين في
كل مره الى استغلال قنوات الاتصال لفتحي
منافذ ديبلوماسيه امام قضايا مستعصيه
قبيله بدا حرب اوكرانيا اعلن البيت الابيض
وان الرئيس الامريكي جوبيدا وافق مبدئيا
على لقاء نظيره روسيه
لبحث الازمه الاوكرانيه شرطه لا تشرع
روسيا في عمل عسكري بعد بدء الحرب انقطعت
الاتصالات حتى منتصف ايار مايو عندما اجرى
وزير الدفاع الروسي سركش ويكو الامريكي
لويد اوستن محادثه هاتفيه للمره الاولى
اكد خلال لها ضروره الحفاظ على قنوات
اتصال مفتوحه بين الجانبين لاحقا في شهر
يونيو
الخارجيه
محادثه هاتفيه هي الاولى بينهما منذ بدا
الحرب وقال بل يمكن انه حتى على قبول عرض
واشنطن للافراج عن الامريكيين معتقلين في
روسيا وفي الثامنه عشر من نوفمبر قال نائب
وزير الخارجيه التونسي ان موسكو مستعده
لعقد حوار رفيع المستوى مع الولايات
المتحده بشان الاستقرار الاستراتيجي اذا
كانت واشنطن مستعده ليك ولكن دون مناقشه
اي شيء متعلق باوكرانيا وفي التاسعه
والعشرين من الشهر نفسه كان مقررا ان
يلتقي مسؤولون روسول وامريكيون في العاصمه
المصريه لمناقشه استئناف عمليات تفتيش
بموجب معاهده يوستارت للحد من انتشار
الاسلحه النوويه لكن اللقاء تاجل
وخلال مؤتمر صحفي مع نظيره الفرنسي مانويل
ماكرون في واشنطن في اول ايام شهر ديسمبر
قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بيدا انه مستعدو
للحديث مع نظيره الروسي اذا اظهر بوتين
رغبه في انهاء الحرب في اوكرانيا وفي سبع
من اشهر نفسه اجره الولايات المتحده
وروسيا عمليه تبادل سجناء شملت اطلاق سراح
لاعبه كره السله الامريكيه بريتنير مقابل
اطلاق سراح فيكتور بوت احد اشهر تجار
الاسلحه الروس وفي التاسع من ديسمبر قال
نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسي نادي
دبلوماسيين روسيا وامريكيين عقدوا مباحثات
في اسطن كل مناقشه ما وصفها بالامور
المثيره للقلق في العلاقات الثنائيه
حذر منسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في مجلس
الامن القوميه الامريكي جونكري جون كيري
بعفوا من ان العلاقه بين موسكو وطهران
تتحولوا باتجاه شراكه دفاعيه كامله تشمل
تبادل الاسلحه والخبره العسكريه بين
الجانبين واضاف الكربي انه واشنطن تنظروا
في خيارات جمع دول عديده لمناقشه التعاون
العسكري الروسي الايراني وانها ستستخدم كل
الادوات لعرقله هذه الشركه واوضح الكيرمي
ان ايران اكبر داعما عسكريا لروسيا اغسطس
اب نقلت مئات المسيرات الى موسكو وقال ان
هناك تقارير تشير الى ان موسكو طهران
تدرسان كذلك انشاء خط انتاج مشترك
للطائرات المسيره الفتاكه وفي السياق نفسه
قالت ممثله بريطانيا في الامم المتحده
بربره ان روسيا تحاول الحصول على المزيد
من الاسلحه من ايران مضيفه ان موسكو تقدم
في المقابل لطهران مستوى غير مسبوق من
الدعم العسكري والتقني حسب وصفها
المزيد من الاسلحه بما في ذلك مئات
الصواريخ البالستيه وفي المقابل تقدم
روسيا لايران مستوى غير مسبوق من الدعم
العسكري والتقني نحن قلقون من ان روسيا
تعتزم تزويد ايران بمكونات عسكريه اكثر
تطورا من شانها ان تمكن ايران من تعزيز
قدراتها في مجال التسلح
قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطوني بليكن
ان الولايات المتحده فرضت عقوبات على 65
فردا وكيانا متوارثين في فساد وانتهاكات
حقوق انسان في 17 دوله واوضح انه تم فرد
عقوبات على مسؤولين روس ووكلاء ساهموا في
استمرار الحرب الروسيه غير القانونيه
والقاتله في اوكرانيا حسب تعبيرها واضاف
لينكن انه تم فرض عقوبات على القوات
الفضائيه الروسيه ومركزات ومركز 924
للمسيرات التابعه للدوله وقياده طيران
النقل العسكري كما اشار لينكن الى ان
اقتناء روسيا للمسيرات الايرانيه ينتهك
قرار مجلس الامن الدولي
2131 ويزيد في تاجيج الزراعي في اوكرانيا
معنى من موسكو ديمتري بابيتش المحلل
السياسي الروسي ومن واشنطن جيمس روبس
روبنز كبير الباحثين في المجلس الامريكي
للسياسه الخارجيه والمسؤول السابق في
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه اهلا بضيفينا نبدا
بالسيد رومانس في واشنطن
يعني هذا القلق الشديد الذي اصبح التبديه
واشنطن من
التعاون الروسي الايراني
نعم نعم
روسيا تستخدم
المسيارات الانتحاريه الايرانيه لمهاجمه
اهداف مدنيه في اوكرانيا وهذه هجمه توقيت
فقط لان
نفذت الطائره
عندما
حرب جديده بها كما انه لو حصلوا على
صواريخ ايرانيه
هي الطريقه تساعد روسيا على زياده شده
وضراوه الحرب لقتل الاوكرانيين ولكن سيدس
هذه الاشارات كانت موجوده في الاشهر
الماضيه هل وصلت الى درجه خطيره تستدعي
التنبيه بمثل هذه القوه
ياسر
الاشاره ذلك لان التعاون بينهما قد تعمق
فهناك تقدر
يدربون في روسيا
والاستخدام طائرات مسيره وايضا هناك
التعاون مخابرات بينهما وايضا هناك انواع
اخرى مساعدات العسكريه اذا هذه العلاقه
فعلا تعمقت واصبحت اكثر مضره باستقرار
بقيه المنطقه في اوكرانيا وفي الشرق
الاوسط وبالتالي في هذا امر يصير القلق
هذا القلق الذي تتحدث عنه الولايات
المتحده كيف ترد عليه موسكو في تقديرك
بوضع في الشغل
موقف الرسمي للحكومه الروسيه هو انها لا
تؤكد ان نستخدم مسيرات ايرانيه وبالتالي
رسميا لم يتاكد هذا الخبر ولكن حتى لو كان
الخبر صحيحا فاستطيع القول انها ليس
الخيار لروسيا او ان ذكركم ان عنده كم
بتزيد رئيسنا كان ذلك في عام 2008 روسيا
لم تقدم صواريخ اس 300 لايران لان ايران
كانت معرضه لعقوبات ونحن نعتقد نفس
الصواريخ ذلك الوقت قدمت الى اوكرانيا
حديثنا وهذه الصواريخ تستخدمنا
في الوضع الذي نجد ان ان عشرات الدول
الغربيه على النبي يسودون الاسلحه
لاوكرانيا فلماذا لا تطلب روسيا الطلب من
بعض الدول حتى لو كانت حديثا قريبه منها
تطلب منها المساعده فالكثير من الدول تقدم
الاسلحه للجيش الاولاني
الولايات المتحده اولهم
وبالتالي يا اما فيما يتعلق مما يسمى
الاستخدام
الشديد لهذه المسيرات فلا يحق للولايات
المتحده ان تتهم غيرها بانك قاسي ووحشيه
في حملها الولايات المتحده كانت هذه اكثر
من ذلك وحشيه في العراق
شامل في العراق
عن روسيا الان قد يكون غير منطقي وغير
صحيحه
هل وصلت الامور فعلا الى
شراكه دفاعيه كما تقول شراكه دفاعيه
انا
لم اسمع اي تاكيد حول المعلومه التي
سمعناها التوام حول طيارين ايرانيين
يدربون يدربون في روسيا هذه المعلومات
تحتاج الى تدقيق لان مصدرها مصدر غير
موثوق به اطلاقا ولكن من حيث المبدا روسيا
وايران والصين دفعوا الى زاويه من قبل
الولايات المتحده وحلفائها الولايات
المتحده الاتحاد الاوروبيه
وعزله ايران
عقوبات على بلدينا وبالتالي سيكون من
الغباء جدا التوقع انه لا يمكن هناك
استعدادات او تعاون بين بلدين اذا نعم كل
اجراء يؤدي الى اجراء مضاد لن تكن روسيا
التي ارادت مواجهه مع الغرب الغرب هو الذي
وسع حدود النيته هو طايحه بالرئيس المنتخب
في اوكرانيا في 2000 همم ثلاثه اشهر
في اوكرانيا وهل الذين هم بداوا بالحرب
الاهليه هناك وما نشهده حاليا مجرد تفاقم
للتلك الحرب الاهليه الناس يتقاتل ما
بينهم يتحدثون نفس اللغه
نفس المدارس المدارس
[موسيقى]
تتعلق بان الان هناك حرب مفتوحه وكل طرف
يحاول ان ياخذ اسلحه من جهات مختلفه في
الوقت الذي تنهمر فيه الاسلحه على الجانب
الاوكراني هل يمكن فعلا لون روسيا عن انها
تبحث عن شركاء اخرين مثل ما اوكرانيا تبحث
عن شركته
طبعا طبعا
لكن نتجه الكثير منهم كثير من الدول
العالم اداء نت هذه الحرب وهي ليست في حرب
اهليه روسيا غزته اوكرانيا في عام 2014
بيقول لك المعظم دول العالم تعرفوا ان هذه
الحكمه هي الا وهي عما الغير قانوني
وعدوان غير قانوني
لهذا يدعو الى تزويد اوكرانيا بالسلاح
القلق الغربي الان هو سيد بابيتش حول
المسيرات الايرانيه وحول صواريخ بالستيه
كما يقول الجانب البريطاني على الاقل هل
هل موسكو تفتقد فعلا
للمسيرات ولل صواريخ البالسيه حتى تستنجد
بايران
انا موافق
في اوكرانيا من الجانب الروسي تكون باسلحه
روسيه ومعظم الاسلحه بتستخدمه
وصناعه الروسيه وهذا يثبت
من ناحيه
التاريخيه انا ولدت فيه في في
واول 22 سنه من حياتي
الجزء الاتحاد السوفيتي جزء من نفس الفضاء
الروسي الحالي وبالتالي
لكن امريكا
مستخدم هي الروسيه وما زالت روسيا يتمتع
بالتوفيق في ما يتعلق بالسلاح ضد اوكرانيا
ولكن المشكله ان الولايات المتحده وهو
اوروبا قرروا
ان يجعل اوكرانيا المكان الذي يلحقون
الهزيمه فيه بروسيا وفيهم يقولون من روسيا
انه ولدنا روسيا تعاني من هذه الحرب وتضعف
نتيجه الحرب وبالتالي يبعثون الكميات
هائله من الاسلحه الى هناك انظر الارقام
التي قدمتها الكونغرس الامريكي سيصل حوالي
100 مليار
مليون عفوا وعظم هذه الاموال تتفق للسلاح
اذا لابد انه الانتباه ان اكثر للاسلحه
الغربيه التي تتدفق الى ايات حكومه
اوكرانيه فاسده اقراوا الصحف
الصحف الغربيه ماذا فساد الحكومه
الاقرانيه سابقا وحاليا وبالتالي فالاسلحه
من الجيش اللبناني فعلا همم
فنلندا وشهدت في الشرق الاوسط وشاهده اخرى
منظم الاحصاءات كم من الاسلحه همم هربت
اوكرانيا خارجه بناء حدودها في التسعينات
في حاله شكله غير هيك اذا
لابد الاتباع عن اكثر ليس الا همم الاسلحه
الاسطوريه الايرانيه الجيش الروسيبال الى
الاسلحه المم فتاكه التي يقدمها الغرب ثم
يتبعه اوكرانيا لدور الاخرى شكرا لك من
موسكو شكرا لك السيد رومانسي
[موسيقى]
داخل الاتحاد مثل هذه الخطوه خوفا من
فقدان التنفسيه مع بقيه انحاء العالم هذا
الى جانب تحذيرا اطلقه البنك المركزيه
الاوروبي مما سماه انعكاسات ماليه سالبه
قد تترتب على تحديد سقفا لاسعار الغاز
للواجهه يعود التباين الاوروبي في احدى
اكثر القضايا تاثيرا على الاسواق الغاز
بعد ولاده عسيره لاتفاق يقضي بوضع سقف
للسهر النفط الروسي تتصاعد نظر انقسام
سياسيا في ملف الغاز الاختلافات الاوروبيه
ليست وليده لحظه فما واقف العديد من دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي ترى واحد بين الرفض
والحذر بل وحتى التحذير في خضم ازمه
الطاقه المستمره منذ بدا حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا وارتفاع معدلات الاستهلاك في فصل
الشتاء لكن وثيقه للبنك المركزي الاوروبي
كشفت عن مواطن القلق المتزايده خلف
الابواب المغلقه وجاء فيها ان وضع سقفا
لاسعار الغاز في اوروبا قد يهدد الاستقرار
المالي
ثم تقال قم يساوي البنك المركزي الاوروبي
بشان الخطوه وانعكاساتها الماليه على
مستوى الاتحاد الاوروبي وذلك مع استمرار
النقاشات على مختلف مستويات العمل المشترك
داخل اروقه الاتحاد الاوروبي من اجل
التوسل الاتفاق بشان اسعار الغاز مسؤولان
اوروبيان كشفان سقف الاسعار المقترح هو
220 يورو لكل ميجاوات ساعه
لكن كل هذه الاقتراحات قد تتغير قبل
واثناء اجتماع وزراء الطاقه في دول
الاتحاد المرتقب الثلاثاء المقبل وللتير
فشله لاجتماع السابق لوزراء الطاقه اواخر
الشهر الماضي في الاتفاق على وضع حد اقصى
لاسعار الغاز الروسي
يتزامن ذلك مع اعلان المانيا وهولندا
والنمسا والدنمارك والاقسم بارك واستونيا
معارضتها توسيعا نطاق السقف المقترح
لاسعار الغاز الطبيعي في سوق الاتحاد
الاوروبي ليشمل التعاملات قصيره الاجل
وحجه هذه الدول ان اي تدخل يجب ان يضمن
الحفاظ على تنافسيه الاسعار في المنطقه مع
بقيه دول العالم
والبديل الذي تطرحه الدول الست اليه تصحيح
السوق بما يسمح بتعليقها اليا وفق فين
محدده يحدث هذا في وقت تتجه فيه موسكو
لاتخاذ اجراءات مضاده لمواجهه قرار وضع
سقف لاسعار نفطها والتلويح بما هو افدح في
حال الاقتراب من اسعار غاز ها الطبيعيه
اول اجراءاته محاكمته بعد اعتقاله بتهمه
محاوله الانقلاب ويواصل مؤيده الرئيس
المعزول احتجاجاتهم رفضا لقرار عزله
واعتقاله في المقابله شرعت
دينارتي نائبه الرئيس المعزول في تشكيل
الحكومه جديده لتسير شؤون البلاد بعد
تكليفها من قبل البرلمان
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
مجددا عاده شوارع البيروك تبز بالاحتجاجات
التي اعتادت عليها خلال السنوات الاخيره
انما بوجوه وعناوين شديده
ومؤيدون رئيس المعزون تدعو كاسيو ومعظمهم
من المعلمين الذين كان يمثلهم وسكان
الاصليين والطبقه الفقيره خرجوا للمطالبه
باعادته الى السلطه واسقاط البرلمان
[موسيقى]
لانه يخالف قرارات الشعب ومن انت اخذناه
باصواتنا هو من يجب ان يبقى في الحكم
ولهذا سنبقى في الشوارع
الرئيس اليسري حاول حل مجلس النواب
للاغلبيه اليمنيه وفرض حاله الطوارئ
وصياغه دستور جديد عبر سلسله من القرارات
الاستثنائيه لمكافحه الفساد وفق انصاره
لكن المطاف انتهى به الى الاعتقال في فتنه
للشرطه ويوجه له خصومه تهاما بمحاوله
الانقلاب على الدستور
الجيش رفض تنفيذ اوامره وسارع البرلمان
الى عزله وتم تعييننائبه الرئيس المعزول
وهي من نفس حسبه رئيسه بعد انضمامها الى
صفوف المعارضه
مجرد محاوله انقلاب في بلدنا قادها السيد
بيدروكاستريو بما يخالف دستور لكن هذا
البرلمان قام بدوره يدستوري وكلفني بتسلم
منصب رئاسه وانا ستحمل هذه المسؤوليه
وادعوكم جميعا للوحده في هذه اللحظه بما
فيه مصلحه بلدنا بتسلم اول امراه حكم
البروج قد استبدلت سته رؤساء خلال اربع
سنوات فقط في احداث وصراعه عاصفه بالمشهد
السياسي
من الداخل بسبب الصراع بين المؤسسات فقط
شهدنا تغير ست رؤساء وسبع حالات شهور
رئاسي منذ عام 2016 اما بسبب شبهات الفساد
والابتهامات او بسبب مصالح شخصيه في
البرلمان لا احد باستطاعته ان يجزم ماء
اذا كانت ازمه الحكم في البيرو ستنتهي على
يد اولده تسكن هذا القصر بعد ما اعلنت
نيتها البقاء فيه حتى عام 2026 الا ان ما
يشغل بالبيروفين على ما يبدو ليس مده حكم
رئيسهم او هويته بالقدرته على حل ازنتهم
التي تزداد تعقيدا وتركما حسن مسعود
الجزيره لما عاصمه البيرو
[موسيقى]
الان ورد للتطورات الميدانيه ودلالات
تكثيف في كل طرف للحجامات على مناطق
بعينها في الساعات والايام الاخيره وقد
تواصلت المعارك بين الجيشين الروسي
والاوكراني في مختلف الجبهات الجنوبيه
والشرقيه وقالت سلطات المواليه لروسيا الى
القوات الاوكرانيه تواصل
بالقذائف والصواريخ وقال مسؤولون
اوكرانيون ان القوات الروسيه قصفت خط
المواجهه باكمله في منطقه الشرقيه
اوكرانيا كما شهدت الجبهه الجنوبيه في
مناطق خيرسون
وميكولاي وبكم موت ودونيس قصفا متبادلا
بين الجيشين الروسي
اما في الجبهه الشرقيه لقد وصل الجيش
الروسي هجماته على المواقع في لوغانس
ودونات
وما احتمال الا تتحرك خطوط الجبهه في
الشتاء يصبح السؤال هو التالي كيف تبدو
استراتيجيه الطرفين في اداره المعركه
حيث يلجا الاوكرانيون بشكل متزايد الى
المسيرات لضرب قواعد روسيه تقع بعيدا عن
الجبهه وفي الايام الاخيره استهدفت عده
قواعد عسكريه روسيه بينها اثنتان تبعدني
500 كلم عن اوكرانيا بمسيره ماذا عن
خيارات موسى
حاليا ومنذ مطلع اكتوبر تشرين الاول
الماضي على استهداف منشات الطاقه
الاوكرانيه سبب ذلك في حربان الملايين
الاوكرانيين من الكهرباء وحتى من المياه
والتدفئه مع حلولي فصل الشتاء الخارجي
المشهد الميداني يطرحوا السؤال هو هل
تغيرت اهداف الحرب التي اندلعت الرابع
والعشرين من فبراير شباط واعتبرتها روسيا
عمليه خاصه
معنا من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا وسهلا بك حضره
اللواء نبدا من السؤال الذي انهينا به هذا
العرض هل تغيرت اهداف الحرب التي اندلعت
في الرابعه والعشرين من فبراير الماضي
نعم تغيرت ليس بسبب الشتاء ولكن سبب تعثر
العمليات العسكريه الروسيه التوجيه
السياسي كان واضحا السيطره على اوكرانيا
عزل القياده الى غير ذلك وظهرت تسريبات
واضحه تحدثت على ان العمليه بنيت على اساس
10 ايام في حدها الاقصى يكون قد تمت
السيطره على اوكرانيا فشل الجزء الاول او
الصفحه الاولى من الحرب في معركه العاصمه
والانسحاب ثم بدا القتال في الجبهه
الشرقيه وفشلت في الجزء الشمالي الشرقي
وبالتالي حصر القتال في الاقاليم الاربعه
تقريبا اللي هو لوجان جوني
وخسرت القوات الروسيه اجزاء في خارج كيف
وخسرت اجزاءا همم شمال نهر اذا نعم تغيرت
الاهداف بحكم الواقع الميداني بسبب عوامل
عديده سواء صمود جيش او الدعم الغربي الى
غير ذلك
ناتي الان الفتره الحاليه هي فتره الشتاء
الشتاء بدا يلقي بظلاله على العمليات
العسكريه لماذا لان القدره القتاليه
للمقاتل وقدرته على استخدام المعدات تنخفض
بصوره كبيره جدا بسبب اولا ظروف الطقس
درجات الحراره
وطبيعه الارض اذا لا نتوقع تغييرا جوهريا
في خطوط العمليات العسكريه الرئيس الروسي
كان واضحا بان عمد المعركه طويل
وهناك اتهام لامريكا ان المعارك همم
امريكا
صممتها على اساس تنتهي مبدئيا في نهايه
2000 2025 اذا دعني اقول فتره لا اقول
بيعه شتوي ولكن هناك تحديدات واضحه جدا
على مجريات المعارك باستثناء نقطه هنا
ونقطه هناك في اطرافه الايمان في اطراف في
باخموت الى غير ذلك ما عدا ذلك فقط هو
تبادل للقسم المدفعي والصاروخي واستخدام
الطائرات والمسيرات لكن هل يمكن القول ان
الطرفين بلغ الحد الاقصى لاستعمال القوه
المتاحه لديهما
يعني نعم في الجانب الروسي همم مجرد اعلان
التعبئه الجزئيه همم الحصول على طائرات
شاهد من ايران الحديث عن التزوج بصواريخ
همم عفوا ذخائر مدفعيه من كوريا الشماليه
استخدام صواريخ اس 300 في دور همم الهجوم
الارضي هذا يدل على انها لا اقول استنزفت
كامبل القواه العسكريه ولكنها بلغت الحج
الاقصى في الاستخدام القوه المتاحه
باستخدام باستثناء الخيار النووي يضاف الى
ذلك اوكرانيا من اليوم الاول تقريبا سجلت
بكافه قدراتها ولولا الجسر الجو الغربي لم
يستطعت ان تقاتل 10 اشهر
المسيرات الان حضره اللواء تلعب دور رئيسي
هل تتوقع ان يستمر لها ان تستمر لها كل
هذه حتى خلال فصل الشتاء
نعم تحديدات الطقس عليها محدوده جدا اثنين
هي تكلفه جديده اذا تحدثنا عن 20,000
دولار للطائره يمكن الان استخدامها باعداد
كبيره جدا من كلا طرفي الصراع لكن الاعلام
الفارقه ما جرى قبل ثلاثه ايام ان يتم
ارسال طائرات قيل انها همم سوفيتيه الصنع
تم تحديثها وتطويرها في داخل الاوكراني
مداها يصل الى 1000 كم وزنها 75 كيلو متر
هاجمت ثلاثه قواعد منها قاعدتين كما اشرت
على مسافه 480 الى 500 كلم وعدت الى الحق
اضرار في القاذفات الاستراتيجيه همم 165
95 نعم ستلعب دورا كبيرا لانها تقتصد في
الجود وفي التكاليف وتوفر او تصفر الخسائر
البشريه في الطيارين
شكرا جزيلا لك لواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي من عمان
ونتابع معكم الان هذه الصور من امستردام
وبيونس ايرس لمشجعين الارجنتين وهولندا في
الدقيقه الاخيره في الوقت الاضافي في
مواجهه الفريقين في دور ربع النهائي
بونديال قطر 2022 النتيجه تشير الى تقدم
الارجنتين بهدفين مقابل هدف واحد
[تصفيق]
منتصف الليل بتوقيت مكه المكرمه وهذا موجز
باهم الانباء قبل الانتقال الى يوميات
المونديال
اختتمت في العاصمه السعوديه الرياض ثلاث
قمه من خليجيه خليجيه وصينيه خليجيه
وعربيه صينيه وشدد قاده الدول العربيه
المشاركون على اهميه تطوير العلاقات
الاستراتيجيه مع الصين لتشمله جميع
المجالات كما التزموا بالتنسيق في قضايا
تمثل مصالح مشتركه من جهته قال الرئيس
الصيني ان المنفعه المتبادله قوه دافعه
للعلاقات المشتركه مؤكدا دعم بلاده للجانب
العربي في ايجاد حلول للقضايا الشائكه في
المنطقه
وفي كلمه خلال انطلاق اعمال القمه
الخليجيه الصينيه الاولى بالنوعها بحضور
الرئيس جيشينج بينج قال ولي العهد السعودي
الامير محمد بن سلمان الى القمه تؤسسه لما
وصفه بانطلاقه تاريخيه جديده لعلاقات
الصين بدول الخليج مؤكدا ان دول مجلس
التعاون تولي اهميه قصوى للرفع من مستوى
الشراقه الاستراتيجيه مع الصين
وفي افتتاح اعمال القمه الثالثه والاربعين
لقاده دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي في الرياض
شدد ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان على اهميه التكامل بين دول مجلس
التعاون وبشان العلاقات مع ايران اكد ولي
العهد السعودي على ضروره التزام ايران
بمبدا حسن الجوار وبالمواثيق الدوليه كما
شدد على اهميه حل القضيه الفلسطينيه وفقا
لمبدا يحل الدولتين اما بخصوص اليمن فقد
شدد ولي العهد السعودي على اهميه الحل
السياسي قائلا ان دول مجلس التعاون ستظل
مصدرا موثوقا لتزويد العالم بما يحتاجه من
الطاقه
كشف رئيس الاوكراني عن صيغه سلامه تشمل
عشر نقاط بينها استعاده وحده الاراضي
الاوكرانيه وامن الطاقه في المقابل قال
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ان عمليه
التسويه في اوكرانيا لن تكون سهله على
الاغلب وستتطلب وقتا لتحقيقها واكد في
مؤتمر الصحفي في ختام زيارته الى قرغيزيه
ان جميع الاطراف المشاركه في عمليه
التسويه سيتعين عليها في نهايه المطار
القبول
بالحقائق على الارض وفقا تعبير
بهذا نصل الى نهايه الحصاد شكرا لكم على
حسن المتابعه والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]